I've got something very important I'd
like to talk about now and who better
discuss it with and my friend Andy
Richter hey Andy I Conan how are you I'm
pretty good as you're aware Andy a lot
of grocery stores have empty shelves
right now they just have they have
nothing to sell they are out of a lot of
stuff yeah yeah shells have been bare
for quite some time but I don't know if
you've noticed there are some some items
that are just not selling at all right
now
one in particular is shrimp flavored
ramen yep I thought that might be where
you're going that's right shrimp
flavored ramen is just not selling these
days for some reason and it's so
noticeable people all over the country
have been posting photos about it on
Twitter yeah check this out even during
times of crisis no one wants the shrimp
flavored ramen
here's another y'all really hatin on
shrimp ramen that much you know Andy I
gotta tell you I'm actually feeling bad
for the makers of shrimp ramen right now
no me too and actually Conan if you
don't mind I would like to help those
people out yeah of course Andy go ahead
okay hey America Andy Richter here you
know it's no secret that times are tough
and the uncertainty can be overwhelming
that's why I reach for the comfort of
shrimp ramen it's all the starchy
goodness and ramen noodles with the
relaxing flavor and odor of shrimp now
yes there's no actual shrimp in the
package but there is a Malto dextran
based powder that when combined with
water vaguely tastes like shrimp and
here's the best part
shrimp ramen is available in massive
quantities at your local grocery store
plus there's a good chance no one has
touched the packaging no risk of germs
with shrimp ramen so take it from me
it's time for your taste buds to social
distance from those other ramen flavors
and head to the deliciousness of shrimp
ramen it's available
wow great job Andy quick question though
why were you laying in bed and why I all
those shots of scantily clad people sex
sells Conan back to you